Wow did they just drop them like flies
[Applause]
[Music]
so I didn't see this one coming we did
we got the announcement late last week
that Luke Cage is not getting a third
season and I know I have to address this
because when I did my video about the
fact that iron fist had been canceled I
mentioned while I acknowledged that
there hadn't been an announcement for a
new season of Luke Cage I also said I
expect one to be coming surely because
if they were gonna cancel it they'd have
done it by now
few days later boom here we go so boy
what do we make of this well the first
thing is this realises how difficult it
can be to know what Netflix will and
won't renew at any given point because
Netflix has released viewer data so this
is distinctly possible that if we knew
what the viewer numbers were for Luke a
season two then maybe we would all have
seen this coming as opposed to being a
bit blindsided by it
unfortunately we just we flat-out don't
have that data Netflix does not make it
public so all we can do is guess and if
I were to guess which I am to guess what
I mean if I were that's what this whole
video is I would say that I would be
shocked if season 2 of Luke Cage had
like crap numbers what I would expect is
that they were probably down from the
year before I wouldn't even think
precipitously I don't think it was a
massive decline but the first season of
Luke Cage was a bit of an event it was a
big deal and well
we got black panther now so I think in a
lot of ways you know not to say that
people didn't still care about Luke Cage
I think in in many ways the some of the
fervor around that first season was you
know we're getting this African American
hero now obviously given Dutch Holland
black feather is an African American
he's just flat-out African but that that
became a much bigger thing especially an
appealing to you know the similar
desires trying to fill a similar vacuum
in terms of your heroic black figure so
I think in some ways what might have
hurt second season of Luke Cage was that
it wasn't the only game in town anymore
now you could argue that you know it's
playing different games movie versus TV
but I would bet you that if not leading
to a decline I would not be shocked if
that was probably a contributor to the
numbers not going up for second season
because I would not be surprised at all
if people who maybe didn't catch the
first season like oh maybe I'll get
around to that but then saw Black
Panther we're like no I feel like I got
my fix I'm good and like this is all
supposition again I don't know so let's
get off stuff that I'm just blindly
guessing about so I'll just wrap up that
bit by saying I don't think it nosedived
and we can't know but I will bet you
that the numbers they definitely didn't
climb and they probably declined a
little bit and Netflix just looking at
the long game probably probably thought
to itself well this is gonna be a you
know just it's just gonna keep going
down year-over-year let's just pull the
plug now so what happens next well I
know there are more than a few people
the very least in my own comment
sections were like oh will probably get
Heroes for Hire now I really really
really doubt that you know as much as
this kind of changes my outlook for the
rest of the Marvel shows on on Netflix
it does not change my opinion that I do
not think they are going to enter
just anything new into the slate I don't
think that Netflix is gonna do any new
Marvel properties I'm actually not even
entirely sure they can even with the
stuff that they've already got because
while they may have the rights to the
characters I'm not sure they're free to
just create whatever show they want with
those characters I could be wrong about
that again I don't know what what
exactly the agreement with Marvel looks
like but I'd be surprised if they kind
of had that level of freedom but even if
they did the the defenders was not an
exceptionally big hit Iron Fist who was
not an exceptionally big hit Luke Cage
appeared to have a very strong first
season but again you know the logic
would be that didn't have as hot a
second season why would they put these
two characters together and yes I say
that knowing full well that the reason
heroes fire was a thing in the comics
was because both characters weren't
doing exceptionally well and Marvel WA
when a well heck slap them together see
if that helps I don't expect Netflix to
actually do that though because they
aren't under you know the same kind of
needs or like what we have to do
something with them I mean theoretically
they you know lose the rice to them but
I don't think Netflix has an expectation
that they're gonna get to renew these
contracts endlessly
I think Netflix is is now treated I
don't think Netflix is gonna do what
Sony does with spider-man which is no
matter what new spider-man movie always
in the works because if they go too long
without releasing one they lose the
right I don't think Netflix is gonna
play that game I think Netflix is
looking at it the same way they look at
anything on their platform which is how
are the numbers what does it cost is
this beneficial to us yeah which is like
the opposite of like I said Sony was
spider-man who's going we know this
property is valuable
even if we're losing money at it we know
it could be valuable we can't lose it
keep it no matter what I really don't
expect Netflix to to have that that
approach in that vibe and I also don't
expect Luke eight now actually honestly
any of the Luke Cage or Iron Fist
characters should open any of the other
shows because the characters in Iron
Fist who were now without
home they would have fit most naturally
into Luke Cage and Luke Cage is gone
what are the three shows that are left
it's Punisher its daredevil and it's
Jessica Jones maybe you could you could
work Luke into Jessica Jones a story but
the thing is I think that's gonna depend
on what they're already planning to do
for her third season because I can't
imagine they're gonna completely rework
Jessica Jones his first season in order
to fit Luke Cage in so maybe if her
third season is good enough that they
want to do a fourth season maybe locate
shows backup for that that's iffy though
I mean whether or not any of these
characters could show up on a fourth
season of daredevil that's hard to say -
I mean feasibly honestly the there could
be some working in with either with
foggy and the and the law firm or with
Karen as a reporter could somehow you
know stumble into these guys that's me
saying that not having finished
daredevil season three yet I'm only a
little bit into that so if the situation
for either Karen or foggy has changed
such where those are that's not going to
be possible
I accept that that's possibility please
don't tell me that don't put that in the
comments don't just don't all right let
the season just came out let people get
through it so assuming that it's even
still viable
maybe but again because they're not kind
of already part of the daredevil story I
don't know if there's a way to slot
those characters in there without having
them just hijack the narrative and again
I don't really see Netflix doing that I
don't think they're that desperate to
hold on to the rights to these
characters oh man I'm not even gonna
mention the Punisher because I don't
think any of these characters really
have any business showing up at the
Punishers show that that really is its
own thing which honestly it should be
I've said before you know I didn't
particularly care for it but Frank off
to the side being his own thing is how
the Punisher works is how the Punisher
has always worked best the more
integrated the Punisher is with main
continuity Marvel I'm talking about the
comics at this point usually the worse
he is pretty much all of
his best stories were in isolation just
him you know maybe a reference or here
or there and daredevil it was a good way
to introduce him as a character but now
that he's off doing his own thing he
needs to stay doing his own thing so I
would say this this seems to me if
anything feels like an indicator that
the bar is high for Netflix's
expectations of these properties and if
they fail to meet they're just gonna cut
their losses so I would say actually
what I had said before which was season
three should maybe be the last season of
daredevil and again I said that without
having finished it that was just based
off the story that that was being set up
and if that gets fully resolved at least
would feel like they kind of blew their
load and there wasn't much left to do
that's a that's a ruder turn of phrase
than I usually use on here I probably
still won't cut it out I should but I
won't so you know there's there's things
like that and then Jessica Jones I mean
we need to see if we can even find his
feet again with a third season cuz it
kinda it lacked the focus that was
probably the strongest element of the
first season it was really focused and
knew exactly what it was doing second
season it really didn't feel like it it
knew nearly as clearly what it was even
supposed to be doing in the first place
and then Punisher I mean again it's hard
to say but I that's kind of got to be
often be its own thing so I think we may
honestly not get to see these characters
again I Typhoid Mary Mary Walker from
second season of of iron fist she could
slot in to daredevil especially easily
enough that is originally a daredevil
character anyways so like maybe and you
know Claire could still turn up anywhere
but she's been in all the shows anyways
so again you know that she's not really
tied down but I think we're done with
Danny which I'm fine with
I think we're probably done with Colleen
who L miss probably done with misty who
all really miss and I think honestly we
might be done with Luke who I'm also
really gonna miss cuz even though I
wasn't the biggest fan of Luke Cage
either season though for different
reasons each time my color was really
good in that part he he just he owned
that he had great presence he had great
rapport and chemistry even with Danny
Rand was like one of the few characters
who he really needed to have good
chemistry but then he did he's one of
those guys who you put him in a scene
with somebody and he makes the scene
better he makes everything with this
other character he's interacting with
feel better feel stronger and yeah I I
hope I hope they find a way to continue
to use them I hope they do it
organically because if you get
shoehorned in then it's it's just not
worth it and I'm also not gonna hold out
hope that that means we now get them in
the movies just because the the the
Marvel movies our they are very much
their own entity at this point they've
got their own thing going on now is it
like a right thing no not really but
it's kind of a fiefdom thing which is
that if you didn't already know the
television and the comics are headed
under one guy guy by the name of Ike
Perlmutter and the movies are handed
under Kevin Feige and those two guys
don't get along now again that's not to
say that you couldn't move from one to
the other but the thing is because it's
been very clear that aside from like the
first one kinda two seasons of agents of
shield that there was going to be
effectively no crossover from the movies
to the TV shows and there's been zero
from you know from the TV back over to
the movies that yeah is it been it's
been really clear that that's gonna be
the case and what that means is even
though Luke Cage and and iron fist and
Miss Teen misty and Colleen are now
untethered from the TV the movies have
been getting planned for how many films
out there already planning without their
presence it's not gonna be worth it to
Kevin Feige to completely redo Gore
his existing plans to integrate these
characters into them it's just not gonna
be worth the bother so I don't see that
happening either if it did happen it'd
be cool but I'm not holding out hope for
that I think we would get a Heroes for
Hire TV show before we would see that
happen and I don't think that's
happening either so there you go Luke
Cage
now both the immortal iron fist and the
man who cannot break have been laid low
what are your thoughts about this does
this change your feelings about where
Netflix is headed what may or may not
happen your hopes your dreams whatever
they are drop something down the
comments let's talk about it there's a
whole bunch of stuff you can do cuz
there's buttons and there's links down
there check them out there's one to my
patreon you know if you feel like
supporting the show and what it does I'm
getting close to hitting my next goal
I'd be able to upbraid the camera how
cool would that be in any case you know
check it out if you feel like it but if
you don't no pressure because at the end
of the day you guys are the council and
I just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]